o Olá pessoal do Tex Uniso tudo bem eu
sou o Mauro Tanaka e para mim é uma
honra muito grande estar aqui
compartilhando nesse dia as minhas
ideias e as minhas invenções a maneira
como eu penso a criação dos instrumentos
musicais E como eu penso a música de
maneira geral eu sou músico educador e
no Tier E aí músico e educador são
funções e profissões que você já deve
estar habituados a ouvir agora o Tier é
que talvez não seja tão comum assim da
gente encontrar né
e o Luthier é aquele profissional que
atua com a construção e reparo de
instrumentos musicais E aí temos aí
desde os instrumentos ditos
convencionais né como eu estudei por
muito tempo a loteria de instrumentos de
corda então eu tenho uma oficina que
faço reparos em violões guitarras e
contrabaixos violinos violoncelo Então
tudo quem instrumento de corda e o ato
no reparo né desses instrumentos mas o
que me trouxe aqui no tadex para trocar
essa ideia e compartilhar esses
pensamentos com vocês é uma vertente que
eu venho trabalhando que é a construção
de instrumentos musicais feitos a partir
de materiais do cotidiano
re-significados né então objetos do
cotidiano re-significados
a gente pode ter desde materiais que são
recicláveis né que poderiam ir para o
lixo ou não e ou objetos comuns do dia a
dia mesmo então a lute ele é não
convencional a loteria alternativa é
isso né Então essa ideia de construir os
instrumentos a partir de dizer objetos
que normalmente não seriam instrumentos
musicais E aí para começar aqui abrir
esse essa conversa eu trago um poema do
Manuel de Barros que tá aqui eu vou ler
para vocês um pedaço então Manoel de
Barros é desvendar objetos o pente por
exemplo dar ao pente funções de não
pentear até que ele fique à disposição
de ser uma Begônia ou uma gravanha
a usar umas palavras que não tenham
idioma Então veja daquele Pensamento
Muito interessante poético né Essa de da
gente imaginar que um determinado objeto
ele possa ser usado para qualquer outra
coisa inclusive fazer a arte e da gente
poder se expressar usando ele né Eu
gostaria de citar aqui deixar que vocês
procurem É também um poema muito bonito
de Orides Fontela chamada ludismo e ela
disse que quebrar o brinquedo é mais
divertido Há controvérsias né mas
evidente que a linha que ela vai né
nesse poema dela que eu não vou levar
vocês peço que vocês procurem por aí é
que você imagina agora você desmonta um
brinquedo de surgem outras peças e cada
peça dessa se transforma num outro
brinquedo né ou seja o que a gente tá
Oi aqui é que nem sempre nem sempre a
gente deve usar os objetos de maneira
que nos obrigam a usá-las né então assim
a aqui não pensa ele saiu para pentear
tudo bem mas ele pode servir para gente
fazer música também ele pode servir Para
apoiar plantas né enfim uma infinidade
esse exercício de desconstruir na nossa
cabeça Essa dureza né Essa essa dureza
mesmo esse molde do pensamento é que
ajuda a gente a ser Teoricamente
criativo inventivo né E aí eu trouxe
então alguns bem poucos objetos que eu
criei né que criei construir na verdade
para compartilhar com vocês para que
vocês tenham uma ideia do que a gente tá
falando então
eu vou pegar aqui ó esse primeiro objeto
você imagina que isso aqui é uma
mangueira uma mangueira comum a
mangueira de Jardim transparente isso
daqui vocês conhecem que é um balão de
festa e aqui dentro Eu tenho água certo
Então olha só
[Aplausos]
E aí
bom então é um som que são faria uma
mangueira cheia de água né Então temos
essa possibilidade aqui tenho aqui
também um dos primeiros instrumentos que
eu construí que eu usei um tubo de PVC
desses comuns LED que todo mundo tem em
casa aí né tubo de marrom e depois de
ser E aí fiz uma pequena modificação
nele aqui né porque essa modificação tem
o nome de bisel né que é onde o ar bate
encontra uma barreira E aí ele produz
alguns sons Então essa daqui é uma
flauta harmônica né
Oi papai
oi oi
a barba
E aí
[Música]
nós temos Então essa flauta que remete a
uma sonoridade aí do Povo nosso povo
ancestral mas o povo nativo né Então
temos aqui com tubo de PVC também a
gente tem essa brincadeira aqui que é um
texto né ter do tubo de fazer ser outros
dois e aqui em um papel celofane E aí a
gente pode ter um som de corneta né
[Música]
temos aqui um caso um instrumento de
sopro aqui simula uma corneta feito com
tubo de PVC com elástico e papel
celofane e
Tá bom eu tenho aqui também
a essa garrafa PET também é super famosa
né Por ela ter ela ajuda na poluição né
a gente encontra nos rios nos mares
bastante dessas daqui boiando pelas ruas
e tal então É possível assistir a gente
colocar ar dentro da garrafa que ela
imita alguns sons né esses aqui por
exemplo
bom então
e esse a gente esvaziar ela um pouco
pouco menos de Aço teremos
E se a gente esvaziar um pouco mais
E aí
bom então é isso quanto mais ar tiver
dentro dela mais Agudos são fica quanto
menos ar
é mais grave
e não é possível E aí com o meu grupo
musical chamado escalafobéticos a gente
tem um instrumento parecido com uma
Marimba on xilofone com várias dessas
daqui Cada uma com uma nota e a gente
toca percutindo né então a garrafa PET e
ar tenho aqui também é um instrumento um
pouco maior esse daqui
é feito com essa lata né de leite e essa
corda e aí temos um som parecido com
berimbau e
oi oi
E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bom então esse é um instrumento bem
interessante que a gente encontra por
exemplo tem um grupo do Ariano Suassuna
um grupo musical chamado o quarteto
armorial que eles tocam Esse instrumento
chamado marimbau também é possível
encontrar nos músicos de blues na então
mostrando que a gente tem aí uma conexão
é dessa confecção dos instrumentos
dentro da nossa cultura ancestral mas
também temos nas outras culturas é isso
tá ligado o evidentemente a os africanos
né ao povo africano escravizado e em
diáspora né que levam a cultura é e esse
tipo de ideia criativa de construção de
instrumentos para poderem se expressar
aí tenho mais um instrumento
e aqui esse é é um instrumento
Originalmente encontrado na África né
Chama a salatu E aí ele lá na África é
feito de uma planta chamada on cova
Espinosa que dá uma cabaça redondinha E
aí eles constroem um instrumento com com
isso né aqui nesse instrumento Eu tô
usando aquelas cápsulas de ovo Kinder
mas também é possível construir com
bolas de natal ou tampa de garrafa PET
enfim e aí é esse tipo de som é
bom então temos aqui ó salatu cápsula de
ovo Kinder miçangas e as dá um bom
divertimento E aí por último aqui que eu
trouxe para compartilhar essa daqui é
uma pá de lixo né com um cabo e aí aqui
no cabo é uma pequena modificação é que
é com uma bexiga aqui na membrana né pra
gente poder fazer um som parecido com
isso então temos aqui eu apago
tá bom aí é isso da onde essas ideias
surgem né muita gente pergunta Nossa que
criatividade e tal e como a gente pode
desenvolver isso em com com todo mundo
né então eu venho usando essas ideias de
construção de instrumentos musicais
usando os esses objetos do cotidiano é
na formação de educadores ou indo para
as escolas escolas de ensino público né
para que as crianças explorem os sons
dos objetos e das coisas na verdade tem
que precisa é suscitar essa curiosidade
que as crianças já tem naturalmente
pelos sons que os objetos fazem esse a
gente deixá-las eles fazerem essa
exploração a colher essa essa
inventividade que elas têm provavelmente
teremos adultos mais criativos tão
O que é isso eu compartilhei aqui
rapidamente as ideias que eu tenho sobre
a música sobre a construção dos
instrumentos e espero que vocês gostem
um abraço grande e até a próxima